so uh let's go give you a good overview
all this stuff like the thing that I
like to do with my talks is never talk
about things that are so grandiose or
highfalutin I want to give you all just
like really really really grounded best
practices and actionable things that you
can take today and go back to your teams
and companies and and see some success
so I'm going to talk about some key to
success some best practices go over some
case studies and then you know some time
specific a lot of time for recap and
kill a all right
uh yes I just kind of talked about this
really just give you practical guidance
help you create a sustainable
self-service High Velocity data culture
so who am I why should you listen to me
I'm the really I am uh seriously uh
right now I'm the CEO of maraxa we build
a platform that allows uh Engineers of
any uh any Engineers of any technical
ability to use real-time data to solve
problems all right uh I'm also an angel
investor so I see some of y'all out here
thank you about my mom on the couch uh
I've been uh an engineer uh so my very
very very first job was at Microsoft and
I uh Azure blob storage is my college
research project worked at Intel worked
at Cisco it's like my engineering street
cred way back in the day uh also was the
first PM is in desk back in the day VSCO
uh Heroku shout out to my home team over
here uh Twitter and I've been the
founder uh so I had a couple
Acquisitions some other things all right
so kind of know what I'm doing up here
again I said I was a all right so
um
but the interesting thing is it's like
every place I've gone I've done the same
same couple of projects right which is
uh one is an internal admin panel uh
which is like clearly my thing right
like if you need an admin panel to be
done or some internal tooling called
Tavares Brown that is like my brand and
the second one is a Consolidated data
platform literally everywhere that I've
been uh all of the aforementioned
companies literally have built the same
project again and again and again which
is why we started maroxa right because I
just got tired one day at Twitter boss
was like yo we need a Consolidated data
platform I'm like look if y'all are
spending 22 million dollars a year on
this uh I probably should go start a
company and that's what we did so
um talk about a little bit of some of
the greatest hits that I've had that
were built on data-driven experiences
and have created massive value so uh the
first one uh at Twitter just kind of you
know one of the things that I thought
was pretty cool
um it was a product called monves uh if
you you know gone
engineering.twitter.com you can read all
about it but we were doing uh 12 billion
observability events a minute uh and
we're growing at 75 year over year uh
only Facebook and Linkedin were larger
than us uh I think at the time uh fun
fact uh we only use about three percent
of that data so uh at its peak so you
know Twitter was a multi-billion dollar
company uh every quarter and uh only
three percent of that data got used
across the organization so uh when I got
there uh they had a hodgepodge of uh
observability tools uh somewhere
homegrown and made because if you all
remember at the time there was no data
dog when Twitter got was was founded so
they built things like storm and Heron
and you know all these things that are
now basically like kind of the the you
know foundation for you know data
processing and all that type of stuff
but a lot of people had left and and so
you basically had like these glorified
hack projects that were running in
production for many years and there were
no semblance of utility or usage across
the organization and so uh we basically
as a team just decided like hey if we're
going to build a massively scalable
distributed uh you know kind of
observability system what would we do we
looked at uh pretty much everybody that
was off the shelf spunk data dog I'm
naming names here so y'all can hear the
pain that we went through because I'm
sure that some of that pain is probably
felt amongst the group but uh literally
talk to everybody that you can think of
and even thought about uh using some of
the the stuff that was off the shelf but
we ended up having to build our own and
oh man every every tweet every
interaction on the Tweet uh so that's
like favorite shares uh views uh every
single time somebody posted something uh
we would we would have to monitor those
things in addition to all of the
infrastructure stuff uh that was handled
so Twitter is just a collection of
services and so we had to get all of the
information off those Services also fun
fact we didn't have tracing until this
project on on any of that so you can
actually send a tweet and not know where
what services it hit throughout the
thing and once we did that we realized
that we had like 60 of the the things
that were running in production were
actually didn't we didn't even need to
use
so that was one of the the byproducts of
this the other thing too that that this
also helped us out with is understanding
performance at scale and so one of the
interesting things that we found out was
like a lot of
um services that were run were not
optimized for uh distributed traffic
right I always wanted to know in college
like hey what does big old notation used
for I found it out uh at Twitter to be
honest right like there's just like
little things that you find out
um and so yeah just having the ability
to collect all these events at scale
across all those Services
um and then being able to visualize that
on the graph in real time uh I mean it
was it's pretty cool so and then being
able to do like the walk back that was
the other thing that was really cool is
like we ended up using believe it was
Flink uh to to do essentially do all of
the um uh joins and stuff on the data
that we had so we can start doing the
preponderance of data so that now when
you get a an event that says hey this is
above our threshold now we can actually
see what it looks like we got the logs
message and Trace metrics and traces all
in one place so it's pretty cool if I
say so myself
um second you know kind of big project
that I led uh was at visco visual Supply
Company how many of y'all are
photographers out here use our filters
and all that type of stuff thank you
um and so one of the interesting thing
was every Friday to Sunday we would Doss
ourselves because uh we were essentially
just a giant WordPress site so people
would wake up on the weekends take a
bunch of pictures and upload them to
visco and every single Friday we would
like go down right and so
and then one day I had the bright idea
to said hey why don't you know I'm
seeing a lot of traffic over in China
why don't we you know localize our app
and to simplify Chinese and then
literally dust ourselves again all right
and it just kept happening again and
again
um so we built this this uh separate
pipeline that essentially ingested all
of that data every single time as a
service that would ingest the photo
um and essentially uh we built a uh kind
of a machine learning pipeline that
would auto tag each one of those things
so instead of
um you know all these photos that were
coming in in real time uh we basically
had a an exclusion list so if we figured
out that it was a screenshot we just
wouldn't wouldn't allow you to post if
we figured out it was a uh adiptits
right like you had a split in the middle
it was a mirrored picture we wouldn't
allow you to post if the saturation was
over a certain level or the you know uh
you know all these little rules that we
had we just wouldn't curate that was the
interesting thing about visco is that
every single picture that that before I
got in there every single picture that
got posted got a pair of human eyes
right on that so basically so we can
curate the best photos and so at the end
of the day
um we reduced the work by like 80
percent and then we reduced the amount
of cost that we had for her for we were
actually paying people to tag our photos
right um and that was something that was
crazy like we had a like a 60 person
curation team we got them down to like
five uh just basically building this
this process additionally the the auto
attacking helped us with search as well
so if you can imagine this is like when
Hadoop came out everybody was like oh
man we want to do the you know the
Lambda architecture and all of that
right and so we were having these
pre-aggregated views and all of that
um it really really helped us uh you
know kind of excel there
um the third project uh zindesk so I was
the first product manager there uh and
we had we were on API V1 had millions
and millions and millions and millions
of people using us all types of customer
service stuff it was great um but we
needed to transform from a product to a
platform all right and really the way to
do that was to basically start building
a a service that was understanding like
how people are actually using our
unofficial API right so V1 essentially
was an API that people use but it was
unpublished we had no documentation
people just basically sniffing traffic
in the browser to understand hey what
calls you can make and then we literally
would see in our logs like you know
Groupon is making you know they they
took down uh gun deals in in their in
their thing and now they have a bunch of
customer service requests that are
coming through their API uh lee was
there uh he knows that day uh and so and
so you know we see all of this happening
through our API because they built all
these custom applications internally and
so we said hey this seems to be the next
layer of growth for us why don't we
figure out what API endpoints people are
using ingested that into hdfs basically
came up with a hit list of all of those
and those were the API endpoints that we
built first for for the customers right
and so you can literally say I wish I
had like a graph like the last guy was
like when I got hired here's where it's
in desk gloves all right and then then
we took off like a rocket ship into IPO
um also too the uh the API V2 ended up
being the the foundational platform for
all of the services that came which were
chat uh you know help desk uh Zinda
Sunshine a lot of the the independent
products that they had right and it was
all forced because of data
um and then the last one typical random
standard thing worked at Microsoft but
probably like half the room here at one
point
um and so uh basically just built the
automation framework we were ingesting
uh data center events uh and you know
something happens go over threshold
essentially just you know respond to
this stuff in real time and and really
had real-time analytics and Status
monitoring across you know largest
instance of SQL Server around the world
and things like that and really reduce I
think we saved them like 60 million
dollars in data center Administration
costs just through the automation
business by understanding how to ingest
data in real time and respond to events
so um um
so I kind of know what I'm doing we kind
of figured this out how many of you all
look like this today you have every
single vendor in every single way yeah
don't lie about it like some of y'all
are out here the reason why you get paid
so much money is because you know how to
navigate the boxes right let's just keep
that real
um uh but you know literally every ore
kind of looks the same right everybody
has data silos there's really no source
of Truth besides that person's Excel
file over an accounting right like that
is the one thing that we know that is
true all the time right all right all
right probably not
um and then time to value is actually
measured in months and and there's a
whole bunch of wasted resources so
essentially like
we know that orgs want to look like this
everybody wants to be an assembly line
self-sustaining collaborative able to
iterate quickly derive insights innovate
but uh to get there there are four keys
to success I'll give you the four P's
right purpose you got to give a damn all
right you got to say that this is a
problem that's worth solving all right
really what purpose means is that
there's a collective understanding
amongst the team of the ideal end State
I guarantee if you talk to to the folks
in your organization across your
organization and say yo what what is our
what is our stance on data
they'll get a bunch of different answers
how do we use data to drive the
organization you'll get a bunch of
different answers all right at some
point you want the same answer everybody
should sound like that cult drone right
like you know when you go into
Applebee's and people are saying happy
birthday you want them to sound like
everybody's in lockstep right
took a while but you know what I'm
talking about right yeah
um
second thing uh people all right uh uh
the personal group responsible for
executing and maintaining the optimal
state
so you got to find somebody that really
gives it down right like they do not
sleep until like everything is perfect
if there's a change that happens in the
system they will be sending you an email
at three o'clock in the morning right
you want somebody directly responsible
that is that is the the overseer of that
vision of that purpose because without
it you know everybody's going to go off
into their own little silos to try to
you know have their own local Maxima but
at the same time it's like hey there's a
way that you can be productive on your
own thing and not run a foul of the
entire system
promise I'm not running for political
office that sounded like a like a
champagne speech but you really want to
find somebody or a group of people that
are responsible for this because without
it no matter what every data project
will fail
all right process and I'm a big
proponent of of process before platform
right figure out how people work what
are the the repeatable execution steps
that people have uh to get their job
done right
um there's a there's a study uh you see
Irvine back in the day
um they had a Mobility study right like
the the campus and they were saying like
people were trying to figure out like
you know why didn't you put any any
cement down before you actually like you
know you're planting grass first all
these walkways and all that type of
stuff so why don't you put any cement
down they said well we just wanted to
see where people walk naturally then
we'll we'll pave over it right so
process before platform and it's really
just a set of coordinated access actions
required to repeatedly and predictively
Achieve those desired results it's all
you want right to go talk to people so
it's funny enough as Engineers one of
your jobs is actually go talk to your
customers all right it's amazing what
you'll find out you'll find out that the
reason why they use Excel is because
they tried somebody tried to build
something internally that just didn't
work every single person that's an
Enterprise company inside of here your
number one competitors Excel
not not snowflake not Oracle not what is
Excel literally you can do everything in
Excel and that's what people are
comfortable with so try to figure out
how you can you can see the processes
they're using naturally augment that
instead of trying to replace that I know
that's controversial me being a data
person that has a data platform but I'm
a realist as well all right
and the last one platform right it's
just essentially just the systems that
it needed to automate the process so
after you talk to people after you see
how they work after you realize like the
things that they're doing are
non-optimal you basically try to figure
out how you can build around that right
and accelerate that
um I would give you some heuristics as
far as like how to measure productivity
but look at the end of the day it's are
people doing their jobs reliably are
they doing their jobs repeatedly uh and
they are they doing their jobs uh to
great success right in the time that
they need it if you can answer that then
yeah the platform works for you until
then probably shouldn't build anything
any questions
all right who remembers the first p
there's always one
good job all right somebody give me
another p
all right good job y'all paying
attention I like that
all right so
go over some best practices
all right uh so I'll give you some high
level guidance all right uh some of this
maps to the four Ps right
um so the first one is the point of
directly responsible individual right
again you got to find somebody that
gives a damn that's going to be the
overseer of all the changes all of the
the headaches all of the complaints for
this right because they're the ones that
are going to understand how to best
navigate the resources and the problems
to get done all right uh you have
to be obsessed with customer and
stakeholder success again as Engineers
you want to build but do you want to
build just anything or do you want to
build the right thing
all right right right
so you have to go talk to people you
have to understand what their what their
success is going to be anytime you sit
down before you write a line of code you
should go talk to the person you're
building the floor and say yo how are
you measured for success
you have to guide them into that path
and you have to do it in the
self-serving capacity
that's actually the best way
it's a little sorry you know as an aside
right like if people don't come to you
with an agenda you can craft that agenda
for them all right so now it's like oh
you can use maroxa with this and that
all right like you want that to happen
good question thank you very much
all right second one uh a third Point
audit and GAP analysis of the processing
platform I talked about this all right
and so uh As You Are
yeah
building things something's verifying
one drive
um as you're building uh you basically
want to understand where the the gaps in
performance with the current process and
the current platforms that they have
right really just sitting down and
interviewing and seeing how people work
throughout the day and not only that
person but understand how the value
chain flows and understand like hey once
you're done building your thing where
does that go who consumes that who uses
that all right and how did they use that
and go talk to that person and start to
see like hey is the output of this thing
exactly what I expected for the input of
this thing right you're basically like
building the human dag right you know
shout out to dads here's the folks that
are here but you're literally just going
out and saying hey does this work down
the chain
um and if it doesn't at any point again
that's where opportunities for you to to
to slide in and do some do some good
work
talked about this before you want to
build around the Blessed cow path so if
something's actually working for it for
you at the company it's you know find
out what it is see how it works but
again you want to build around it
augment the people be the lucious Fox to
their Batman all right uh give them the
tools to go do things that are heroic
versus you just building for building
sake
and then the last thing is just measure
the time to Value right and that really
at the end of the day you want to figure
out if I have a thought that if I want
to go out and and answer a question with
data uh how long does it take me to get
from question to to identifiable result
depends on the company because of all of
the the stuff that gets in between there
but establish a baseline first and then
work your way back and figure out ways
that you can optimize that
any questions so far
cool
all right Secret Sauce so I'll just talk
about the real uh real time first one
self-serving right y'all came here
because you know everybody's thinking
about real-time data and streaming and
all that stuff now how many of you all
are doing streaming or using real-time
data at your company Costa uh with
pulsars yeah maraxa you know all these
companies Flink you know if you're using
that yeah you want to think real time
first all right uh real time gives you
the benefits that batch doesn't uh one
of the things is the granularity of data
and the other cool thing is that you can
always go from real time to batch you
can't make batch faster it's literally
like a physics problem
um and so as you're getting the events
as as it comes in versus you doing this
giant lift and shift or automated copy
paste Pete you missed a Daxter shout out
that I had already
um and so like you do all these things
um and again it's it's it's literally
you can reduce the amount of footprint
that you have I mean you can react in
real time right like that's one of the
things that that we've learned quite a
bit um over time
uh uh you basically need a known set of
data components mapped to a specific
need all right so if I am an analyst or
if I am a data scientist figure out what
components that you need for ingest
transform to do all the data munging to
store that data to visualize that data
right and just have one every single
company I go into depends on the team
everybody does things just a little bit
differently the Nuance point of that is
it's like the point of consumption can
change right where I visualize it and
all that
but actually building the data products
that needs to be stable and that needs
to be a known set people need to know
that hey if I need to go understand what
my sales data is doing where my what my
marketing data is doing they need to
know to go to one place have one blessed
workflow and then they can use whatever
consumption tools that they use they
want to but that data product that sits
in front of that that has to be
said
the other thing since you have somebody
that is directly responsible individual
a half quarterly audits for relevancy
and freshness right like that's one
thing that every time I go into to a new
company or talk to a new data person
um even my own company like data
companies are notoriously bad for for
having analytical data right
um and so you really have to go and and
look at those dashboards look at those
charts look at the you know the
spreadsheets that you're using to
understand it does this data is this
data still applicable does it still
matter for the problems that I'm trying
to solve or the messages that I'm trying
to communicate
um another thing insert teams demo and
publish their products right I can't
tell you how many places I've been to
where it's like oh this random engineer
did this cool thing uh and we kind of
use this off to the side uh but here's
the other thing that everybody else uses
but there's other thing that this
engineer does it's kind of cool off to
the side it's actually what everybody
else needs to do but they just use it
you know built it in their in their in
their spare time right like again you
have to have this culture of show me the
execution uh talking to other people not
only to my my stakeholders but talking
to uh you know uh the people around your
organization that could potentially
benefit from the work that you've done
sounds simple but I promise you a lot of
people just don't do that
and then if you build an artifact
whether that is with code whether that
is SQL or you know python or your
notebooks or all that you just use
GitHub right like do not have this thing
sitting on your machine forever put it
up in GitHub
try to read me and say this is what this
particular piece of SQL is for this is
what this particular python is for right
like so that way somebody in your
organization can pick that up and see it
optimize it use it whatever it is they
want to but again it's a sharing sharing
culture and Community that's out there
[Music]